salut à vous peuple d internet nous
sommes presque à la moitié de ce
calendrier de l'avent c'est le onzième
jour nous sommes 11 décembre
et comme tous les jours à 6 heures du
matin je vous parle d'un thème mais
toujours aussi d'un cadeau potentielle
annuelle qui pourrait vous plaire
puisque à priori si vous êtes sur cette
chaîne c'est con à peu près les mêmes
goûts et l'année dernière en 2016 et un
petit peur 2017 vous êtes parler de
rhétorique de répartie de l'art d'avoir
toujours raison
je parle de mon engouement pour ça ces
issues de l'art de la répartie de
schopenhauer alors schopenhauer il a il
a écrit ça hein l'art de la répartie qui
est sûrement le plus grand traité de
répartie mais surtout le plus rentrer
était de mauvaise foi pour pacy dans
l'art d'avoir toujours raison qui existe
à ce jour mais le texte n'est pas si
simple à comprendre
c'est pas si évident que ça parce que la
réflexion est très bonne et très
pertinente et bien tu me crois tu me
crois pas 1 quelle surprise
ils avaient été hachés ça sur ses genoux
il ya une édition qui est sorti chez
librio qui coûte 3 euros
eder 1 2 et 3 euros je trouve pas ça
cher du tout c'est aussi pour ça que
vous en parle et il reprend 38 des
meilleurs stratagème de schopenhauer et
surtout les commente
et c'est ça qui est intéressant ce
délire il prend des exemples et dans les
exemples il prend des exemples très
contemporain de joux fausses tombes sur
ce crac et idem très contemporain
exemple de l'exemple du stratagème 8
je vous le dis quand même le stratagème
il consiste à mettre l'adversaire hors
demi la colère est en mauvaise
conseillère il ne sera plus en état de
forme et un jugement juste et de voir où
est son intérêt le moyen le plus sûr de
le faire sortir de ses gonds et de
provoquer ouvertement de couper les
cheveux en quatre
sur jamais reculé devant qu
l'irrévérence ça c'est le texte original
de jusqu'au nord est donc là on à
l'intérêt du stratagème et la mise en
pratique par l'auteur et ensuite exemple
quand je dis contemporain il date un
petit peu assez d'exemples du 27 octobre
est ce toujours plus récent qu'est-ce
que l'effet championnat de pha
c'est une émission de télé sur tf1 entre
sur un débat entre fabius et jacques
chirac
en fait l'idée de jacques chirac était
de casser de briser
belle image qui avait fabrice auprès des
français de sang froid de tout ça et il
y arrivera avec ses stratagèmes la
loyale chiraquie dit les
nationalisations santa système qui a
prouvé qu'il est mauvais je voulais
faire un peu marionnettes ce sera plus
clair ça c'est fabuleux
ça c'est chirac et ça c'est les
présentateurs des nationalisations des
s'est passé monsieur chirac sinon on va
pas s'en sortir
oui mais j'aimerais qu'ils me répondent
écouter l'ata qui consiste à vouloir en
permanence parce que ça vous gêne
interrompt pour essayer de déstabiliser
l'adversaire elle ne sert à rien car ce
n'est certainement pas vous monsieur
fabius qui allait me déstabiliser vous
imaginez bien bon ne vous énervez pas ne
vous énervez pas j'ai de ce point de vue
au moins autant d'expérience que vous et
par conséquent vous ne risquez je
reconnais que vous avez plus
d'expérience politique que moi alors
soyez gentils nous laisser parler cesser
d'intervenir incessamment un peu comme
le rock n est ce pas et là c'est à ce
moment précis que laurent fabius va
faire un geste très énervé de la main
pourrait se voir ça sur les internets on
retrouve encore la trace de ça et qui
dit écoutez vous vous adressez au
premier ministre de la france
non je parle à monsieur faible jusqu'aux
représentants du parti socialiste alors
cessé de qu'est ce que c'est que ce
comportement et la chirac lui prend tout
son calme pour le dire écoutez monsieur
fabius cessé de m'interrompre
indéfiniment vous serez comme ça
qu'elles sont mes raisons et en fait
dans le fond tu abuses avec les 13 ans
sur les nationalisations à l'époque mais
comme il a été manipulé par jacques
chirac c'est lui qui s'est énervé
réellement premier qui est émis en plus
des gestes d'énervement et ce qui a un
peu cassé son image à l'époque voilà et
donne même état d'esprit il existe un
autre livre encore moins cher donc plus
petit il coûte deux euros 99 lui avait
nié y a des il ya des effets de malades
qui s'appelle la de la répartie de
séverine denis qui lui est chez first
lui et chez librio alors j'étais un peu
surpris en achetant je pensais qu'on
était un petit peu dans le même délire
que ça ait en fait oui mais non c'est à
dire que bien sûr on va voir plus sur la
répartie que sur la mauvaise foi
d'ailleurs ça c'est intéressant
la vraie répartie arriver à contrer
certaines situations il ya des bons mots
aussi de répartie dedans genre d'aidé
des échanges par exemple il ya il ya une
femme un jour qu'il a dit est de
chercher si j'étais mariée avec vous je
verserai du présent dans votre verre que
de chercher qui lui répond madame si
j'étais mariée avec vous je boirai
sévère au siv est marron après c'est
peut-être une légende urbaine mais c'est
toujours intéressant de stimulants en
tout cas d'imaginer ses réponses là et
pourquoi je dis que ça va un petit peu
plus loin parce qu'on parle de comment
capter l'énergie des échanges les types
de répartie les situations nécessaire
pour la répartie est ce qu'on est obligé
des drôles ou est ce que tout le monde
est drôle sans le savoir comment être
dans le moment présent
ici maintenant mais là c'est intéressant
on n'est plus sûr de la pnl et du
développement personnel mais on se rend
compte que pour avoir de la répartie il
faut aussi être vraiment dans l'instant
une espèce de truc ou nagui on dirait de
run the world girls vandamme
mais il ya un petit peu de ça un des
premiers chapitres sur comment libérer
son imaginaire aussi voilà il ya tout le
processus aussi pour se mettre en
condition et optimiser sa présence et
optimiser sa présence
et optimiser sa présence pour après
avoir la répartie je trouve que les deux
ça ceci très bien ensemble et c'est pour
ça que vous en ai parlé que je les mets
dans la description de cette vidéo
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo vous
pouvez laisser un pouce en l'air si ça
vous a plu
on se retrouve demain pour la moitié de
ce calendrier de l'avent a beau nous
aussi c'est pas déjà fait ciao over clap
je ne sais pas qui joue à tout ça mais
je le dis dans notre
[Musique]